so you can
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
perfect
[Music]
yo what's up everybody i am thomas
dopasiola whatever you want to call me i
am here with my co-host marty o'neil
what's up folks what's up guys this is
the dopes usual podcast we're here to
talk about life drugs problems
accomplishments and everything in
between
today today's podcast i've had since you
know what
let's just get into it all right let's
just get into it guys this is a guest we
are very excited to have this is lena
the plug
hi everybody say it right yes you said
it correctly i'm very honored to be here
in your first time with your new yes set
up first guest new setup looking good
i'm i'm excited thank you for being here
yeah of course you i think might be the
only guest that showed up directly on
time thank you i was all sad because i
was like four minutes late
no that's perfect time thank you so do
you guys like leave a bunch of room in
your schedule because most people are
like what half an hour late or something
we tend to just we give a little bit of
leeway just hope yeah this hoe because
hey where are you yeah hurry no we're
never going to do that but it's nice
like on time let's get no i felt bad i
was like i'm four minutes left i hate
being late to stop yeah me too i will go
on super sport mode and smash if i have
to get somewhere
it's the worst that's the worst that's
the worst feeling on earth rushing
somewhere against a podcast or something
so speaking of podcasts i i mean i
follow your pages i follow adam's pages
pages
you have a lot of shows you work a lot
uh i i do i guess you do i mean
i we have one
and it's a lot of work
we have plug talk and i've been on no
jumper a lot but it's not my show i feel
like a lot of people used to think it
was my podcast too and then now um i
just launched my podcast yesterday
but i like still feel weird saying that
i have a podcast because it's so new
well i feel like
this other being a part of a show i feel
like you said no it's my show but no
it's our show
you're on the plug talk that's a full
that's a job in itself yeah we try not
to shoot it too often so we don't like
get sick of it because it's like when
you do it once a week it's like really
exciting you know but we'll do like
multiple episodes a day
yeah oh yeah that's a lot of work
a lot of rounds yeah that's a lot touch
of makeup in between wash your body well
you have a whole you have a whole
production with you um
we have a crew of like two to three
people audio guy filmer
um you know production manager set
manager um and then the talent that come
in but really like the whole episode
from start to finish from like filling
out paperwork to the end takes like two
hours maybe paperwork like nda's or
something no like if you know there's
like um
paperwork that you have to do by law
to make sure the person's 18 and make
sure they consent to like some model
release basically they take photos of
the ids and all that kind of boring
stuff yeah the stuff that nobody cares
about i mean well it's like because
we're having sex on the podcast so you
have to like make sure everything is in
order i just want to think it's a great
business model i think it's the best
because
that's literally what you do do you want
to accelerate your brand a little let's
all do it together that's how i see it
every time i go on someone else's
podcast now the joke is like oh i wonder
what they're going to do at the end of
the podcast we're not going to have sex
on this podcast but on my podcast that's
what adam and i do we have sex
with the talent well the comments would
have said because now i started my own
podcast and i've already seen some
comments like how is this one gonna end
i wonder if they'll have sex this is
just for this is your show this is
everything you because plug like i get
it no jumper i get it i understand that
like
something like this is mine i created it
yeah well cause it's like
i oh i mean even though i have a large
male audience i do have a large female
audience that i feel like i connect to a
little bit more and i've always wanted
to be able to be myself and so my
podcast is more like the questions that
girls would probably want to ask other
girls in the adult industry like when
the girls are telling their stories on
plugtalk i wanna ask questions and i
really hold back because it's gonna take
the show to a very unsexy place and the
whole point of the show is for people to
be masturbating and
you know going to completion and if i
ask a question about like your dad how's
your dad you know or like how did that
make you feel on set like what did that
do for you when the director said that
like it's just
you know emotionally like it's just
people are gonna get really soft real
fast
x out so touchy subject which is my
podcast is where i can you know ask
those questions that i really really
want to itch to ask of course
when we were thinking of questions
because you said there's another
perspective i know a lot of you have a
girl audience yes
when we're doing the question like you
know what i don't have a girl's
perspective of this i need a girl's
perspective of what questions that a
girl would ask so that's exactly what
you do you fill in that void of yo i had
a oh i'm not going to talk about that
here well yeah i really am like a little
a little mute sometimes on plug talk
because i'm like i don't know the
questions are very like
how was your first anal sometimes you
know and it's like
i don't care as much about that question
as i do about the other things yeah so
you've had one episode so far i've
filmed a few but i've dropped one no i
had to so i wouldn't stress myself out
so you're filming multiples a day
and actually adam is doing my podcast
tomorrow which when i first started was
starting it he said i'm not gonna be
under podcast i'll be on like episode
20. like i want you to like do your best
on your own and then he was like
actually i'll be on your podcast i
really want to talk about our vacations
okay oh so now he has an outlet to go oh
the way i always see it because he's in
such a culture that
dudes don't want to smile like dudes all
stand like this
chain or money's like it's cool to me in
another environment i could be a dad it
looks like this disney picture like
that's how i think for him too is like
he can't live any part of his life
without actually becoming content and
he's like going to vegas so he's like
i'm not gonna have an opportunity to
talk about this vacation on my podcast
so i'll do it on your podcast i'm like
okay um but it's funny because my
podcast that is like very girly and very
painful
and like i am very excited to see him
sitting in the podcast chair
it's like his adventures channel it's
like his yes i have another channel
where i don't smoke weed or don't cuss
or don't do anything that would get you
flagged
and it feels
like
i feel i feel different yeah but i'm
sure with him too it's an outlet for him
because you're saying his whole life's
content i i feel and understand that
struggle slash
opportunity i get it he's like i did all
this i didn't do anything with it i see
he would really do it if he didn't tell
everyone about it well that and more of
yeah i can write this off this whole
vacation to my cpa parts of it if i just
film it that's how i feel a lot of the
time that's true yeah whose idea was
plug talk this has got to be the first
of its the first podcast of its kind
right
so
how did i mean it came about like we
started working on it during quarantine
i when i was pregnant
we kind of saw how like a lot of people
started to do
sexy content but it wasn't quite porn
like i don't know if you guys know
vitali here at that site vitali
uncensored where because he was on
youtube yeah the prank guy so he was
doing like pranks on a website remember
him and they would just like have
titties out or whatever it wasn't like
sex sex it was just like a little bit of
nudity and we saw that and we were like
kind of like what's our version of that
and
we were like why don't we do a podcast
that's like adam's thing and then the
porn things like my thing
and just blend our two ideas together so
we actually were sitting on episodes for
like a year and then we finally dropped
last november and it's weird because i
was like really pregnant in the first
few episodes and then when we finally
released i like wasn't pregnant anymore
so everyone's like what the [ __ ] is what
happened is she pregnant again i was
like no no these officers are kind of
old
um
yeah so then it took a while because i
like
you know it's not really easy to find a
place to shoot porn so i was like i
bought a separate house so that we can
actually shoot plug talk there so we
have our own studio but it's a house so
now we just crank up so it's like once
or twice a week
wow that's i mean the concept of it is
my do you remember
there was like the taboo [ __ ] you have a
playboy tv channel at your house you're
rich remember those kids like i have it
at my house it was like the taboo crazy
thing remember like ebon's world and
rotten.com all that crazy [ __ ] so when
people introduce me down like there's a
playboy channel on tv and these porn
girls
and models would talk about sex scenes
on the show and have call-ins
of people live talking so this one scene
in this wonderful and this one episode
oh gotcha so this is really what
happened she tells us wow i didn't know
about that that's really interesting i
mean my friend sorry anthony me my
friend anthony able he turned and i go
he's like my mom's got to tell me this
is weird
also i'm only like 11. so i thought yeah
you could have not looked gonna go to
hell bro
because i was a kid and you know people
you better not close your eyes any sex
scenes close your [ __ ] eyes look that
one i know so when playboy tv it shocked
the hell out of me so i feel like
your guys's show is like an updated
version
of that minus the craziness except you
found a way to
monetize the adult film end
yeah i think it's awesome it just makes
it different too because it's like i
feel like i mean now more and more girls
are getting to go on podcasts but for
the most part the average girl who's in
the industry probably doesn't have like
a platform to talk about herself on and
she probably has really interesting
stories some of the girls that are
lesser known that we've had on plugtalk
have had the most interesting stories
and i'm just like god i could hear her
talk forever and so i feel like that
aspect is really fun for girls they get
to come and share about themselves and
then they get like a scene out of it you
know because like we have the scene on
the plug talk only fans but we also give
it to the girl so she's free to sell it
herself and so it's still content trade
which i like like as a model that's the
kind of like business offer that i would
want someone to give me because that's
the way that i can make the most money
off of my content so it feels really
good to be doing it that way versus like
a company they just pay you a flat rate
you're there all day and exploit it
forever and then they sell it forever
and you just got your one day's pay you
know that's i mean i could see the
incentive of someone who wanted to come
on on top of the exposure now you're
getting like you said work out of it
yeah and it is work it's sex work it's
it's an actual job it's an actual job we
pay actual taxes real career no it's
real yeah
so question you said during quarantine
you thought about it i noticed i've seen
the only fans stuff at first i just
thought it was memes of you know only
fan and then you saw the logos you know
how things catch what is this i've seen
it 13 times a day yeah so when i saw
only fans i thought
is this good or bad for the adult
industry but
in terms of corporate stuff individually
i think it's great correct because now
people will have
a platform to
get it out to the masses i guess more
and at first it was more taboo and now i
see it as what do you do oh i i do only
fans
straightforward like that's just my job
yeah just like oh i'm an adult i'm going
to say being a recording artist almost
like i don't need the label as much
that's how it exactly yes
yeah and
it's like
there's there's i think it's great for
everyone i mean it was not great for the
horn studios because there's like a
little bit of less incentive for girls
to want to work for them because if they
can get their own exposure on social
media through collaborating with other
girls or purchasing shout outs or
whatever it is then they don't really
need the studio and you know they they
make all of their money on the other
hand they also have to like
work like a true business woman they
have to plan all their shoots and make
sure they're catering to their audience
and answering all their messages and all
those things and if you're not the type
of person who wants to do that stuff
it's not going to be good for you if you
want to just show up to set and be
treated like you know talent like a
princess and they cater to you they do
make up everything then that's great for
you but um with the pandemic you know
obviously a lot of people didn't have
jobs they were losing their job so a lot
of people went to only fans and so it
just became such a big name which i
think is great because when i walk into
a bank and the accountant pulls up my
account you know they're always like
so what do you do for a living and i'm
like oh my god they're asking me this
question again and last time i went to
the bank i was like only fans and the
guy didn't ask me anything else and i
was like great like my job is sort of
legitimized by the fact that everybody's
aware of what this thing is
and so i don't really have to explain
myself that much anymore versus before
it's like well i'm a youtuber and
actually i really make most of my money
from creating adult content online so
you're a porn star well i don't really
work for any company you know it's like
it was like a whole thing only fans
became normal in like two years normal
yeah like a hundred percent like like
what zoom did to skype but there just
wasn't anything there before it now only
fans was part of like the zeitgeist it
did what uber did at taxis yeah yeah it
allowed you to be your own boss i mean
girls still shoot for companies and all
the companies are still very popular of
course but
if uh if a girl has her own exposure
from you know creating an instagram or
tick tock or whatever then she could
really just make an only fancy herself
all you really need to be successful on
only fans is to have an audience then
you can probably go get paid more when
you book commercial shoots if you have
yeah because then you can um you know
put more pressure on the rate they're
going to give you because obviously if
you don't have any following then they
can just give you a low volume on the
rate but yeah yeah and it's not just
oh you can go why don't you just get it
i hear that a lot get a regular job
it's not a regular job is pay i ha i
know one person
that i'm not going to say everything you
know her too
she makes i mean six figure mid six
figures a month
a month
that is amazing someone farts
no you don't have to do all that [ __ ]
some girls just take like photos and
some girls do the whole thing you know
but to put it in perspective like
i started doing adult content online
before only fans even existed so it was
2016 and back then it was like private
snapchat was the thing so basically
you would ask me if i had a private
snapchat and i would send you to my
website and you would like snapchat was
used for porn back in the day yes but it
was like it was called
third party app so it wasn't like
officially through snapchat you would
basically pay 30 bucks a month to be my
friend on snapchat and then i would add
you and then you'd get to see my story
and my story would have nudity on it and
back then you know i had maybe
i would say between 25 and 50 000
followers on instagram and my first
month i decided to do it i made just
over 30 000
so and that's like me being a very small
creator back then so it's like there is
a lot of money in it and only fans only
made it easier to make money because
there's so many different ways you can
monetize on the actual platform was it
hard adjusting to youtube comments or
just like you have a whole different
type of people watching you now or like
critiquing you on youtube
well so i wasn't like gonna pursue
youtube really and then i met adam and
adam was like he comes from the youtube
space he's like gotta make youtube
youtube channel like look at hot girls
do so good on youtube you know he was
kind of trying to be like my manager a
little bit
and uh so i just made a video it was
maybe like two minutes i didn't really
try at all i just sat there and was like
okay
if i get a million subs i'm going to
make a sex tape and it was just like a
joke because i had seen another girl try
to make the same comment and she did not
get a million subs it didn't become the
spiral thing but when i did it it went
super viral like worldstar was the first
one to post it and then everyone picked
it up after that it was on like the
yahoo home front page like wow i did
like random radio shows in like south
africa like it was so [ __ ] viral
and when that happened it was like i
didn't get to dip my toe into being an
influencer or being famous or whatever
it just like really happened all at once
and obviously the is like
girl's so desperate she says she'll make
a sex tape if she hits a million
subscribers which like now in the only
fans era i don't think that's even a
story i don't think that story goes
viral i don't think it's a big deal at
all you have to say the craziest [ __ ]
you have to say like you [ __ ] your
cousin on only fans in order to become
really popular or make like a big viral
splash right but back in 2016 i think it
was like january 2017 that this happened
i got so much hate like people were
saying that i was like this crazy
desperate loser and i really sat there
like holy [ __ ] should i have done this
like people are looking at me in such a
terrible way like it kind of made me a
little depressed but then i had adam who
was like okay this is this is all just
good like don't worry about it and
obviously it did make me a lot more
money it did make me a lot more famous
and i think that story is like what has
allowed me
to have longevity because
i don't think that
only fans the people who make the most
money on only fans are the prettiest
people they're not like yeah being
attractive helps but it's really like
the story and the thing that makes you
go viral that makes you popular and that
makes you the most money
yeah you can remember these
like when you just said it was private
stuff like wow i forgot that was a huge
wave yeah it was before
lincoln bio only vance lincoln before
all these little trends started so i
it's like i said when pandemic started i
have a lot of model friends that started
doing only things
and now they're
they're crushing it and i think it's i
think it's great it's a it's a way to
monetize yourself if you are already
doing modeling you're already doing this
you're already taking near nude photos
right like on your page you're right
taking the pictures
and and then
the thing that people always say oh
who's paying for that what guy is really
paying for that there are so many dudes
out there that are just so
busy
and or lonely and we're just straight up
cannot talk to girls i mean some people
just buy it out of curiosity like if you
tell a ridiculous story
then people just want to know a little
bit more about you they're really
curious like what is she actually
posting on her page you know what i mean
um
and uh
yeah i don't i don't know people just
really like
they they say in the comments like oh
that's so gross that's so nasty i would
never want to be with someone like this
but then all these group of people
coming to subscribe you know so there's
something for everyone like
the
um i just was on flagrant and i was just
saying how i think it's like
gross that people ask me to talk about
like mommy stuff on my page because i'm
a mom now so everyone's like really into
the milf thing with me oh i'm the only
fan yeah they're like oh like tell me
all about your mommy milkers and stuff
like that and like i was saying how i
didn't like that and uh flagrant posted
about it and that like did really well
for myself so it's like
you just never know you put on your page
like please no like
like mommy [ __ ] please don't be a creep
yeah like does only fans have like any
like there's tons of rules
there's definitely things you can and
can't say um i remember the first thing
i was shocked by it was like 2018 and i
went to type like choke you know it's a
really common thing to say like oh i
want to choke on his dick or whatever
it's like that is not a word you're
allowed to type it it's it doesn't let
you you can't even say the word no
there's like a lot of rules
um because they don't want people
[ __ ] choking themselves dead on only
fans i would imagine i guess there's
like just so many things you're not
allowed to type and especially now like
the rules have become so much more
strict because the credit card companies
will basically go back and forth with
the porn companies like we're not going
to let you use our credit card
processing if you allow this and this
and this and this so like no no
no that's your thing
okay i understand because they rely on
the on the billing systems you know to
be successful is crypto big for like
porn actors and actresses do you guys
get paid like that or not so much i
don't know if you can use i don't think
you can buy stuff on only fans with
crypto maybe sure i mean i think if the
credit card companies decided like no
we're not allowing you to use our
processors anymore then
probably we would have to like really
get into crypto
but only fans probably isn't going
anywhere like that's what they signed up
that's exactly what my next question was
i don't think it's going anywhere um i i
think it's still up in the air if they
decide to take adult off their platform
and i think it would really take adult
dog well last contest august they said
that they were no longer going to allow
adult content on their platform and it
was like a certain date that you had to
have everything removed by or whatever
and everyone was freaking out um i was
really worried and like there was a lot
of um
people really upset because it's like
the reason the platform is big is
because of adult creators
and then now you have like traditional
more um you know
mainstream influencers on the platform
who get to use it and get to post the
links and their bios and everything like
that and they don't get like in trouble
for that sort of thing but it's patreon
yeah exactly use patreon but it's it's
you know the thing is like a lot more
people know what only fans is than what
patreon is so it's like if there was a
new platform tomorrow that had offered
the same exact things as only fans i
would still choose only fans because
people trust it people know what it is
and so because i remember back with
private snapchat people would always be
like are you just going to steal my
money what is it going to stay on my
statement is like my wife going to see
the whatever so it's like people really
want to trust what they're buying and
with only fans they feel like they can
trust it what a question will my wife
see oh but you probably have the
craziest stuff in your dms and i i don't
really i try not to look at you you
probably have just such a
different perspective on men in general
well that was another question
when we booked when we talked to your
manager i thought you know what
i have a question i'm going to help a
lot of [ __ ] out there and i
thought you know what my segment's
called help a [ __ ] out
you know i know i would say 97 of guys
cannot talk to girls i would say maybe
even higher percentage than that he
you're a jerk he's great he's crushes it
he's amazing with that but he's i'm like
so what would your advice be to a
regular ready
regular looking guy not super attractive
dude doesn't get a bunch of money grew
up on the internet texting what a great
show but a super nice person
super funny
how is he gonna go talk to a girl at a
bar like what is the thing that's gonna
make you go you know what didn't creep
me out this guy's interesting because
there's a lot of dudes out there that
have no idea what they're doing can't
talk to a girl it's so hard to give like
a blanket piece of advice because i feel
like most girls would agree that like
one guy could come up to a girl and say
like
hey you look really beautiful and and
they'll be like that guy was such a
creep but then another guy could go up
to the same girl and say this same exact
thing it's like some of it is intangible
like when you can smell the thirst on a
guy
it really turns every girl off and agree
it's not something that you can like
physically always see but it's just i
can't even teach you yeah yeah and so
it's like don't be
don't seem overly thirsty don't seem
like you never get girls you know and
and you just have to try like if you go
up to girl and you're like like make eye
contact don't be awkward don't be weird
just look at her if she turns you down
you're just you know the same place you
started you didn't have her to begin
with it's like you got her
can i buy you a drink can i talk to you
for a second but like not in a weird way
like hey can i holler at you don't be
like that you don't just be like forward
so gross it's never not gross
unless you're just the super g i was
just in new york city walking around the
streets and i forgot that like people
just can't call like crazy i don't
really walk around in l.a oh yeah you
know i drive everywhere so i'm walking
around in l.a and i'm by myself and i'm
wearing like you know kind of a workout
outfit like you know if you want to say
it's sexy sexy whatever but i'm just
like by myself like hey girl hey hey hey
and i'm like has
never worked for anybody
has that ever worked on anyone
[Music]
people in new york will just come up to
you and start talking to you anyway like
everybody's oh he's from new york the
people it's different we were i was like
walking around near like central park
and stuff and you know there's
just so many more people so it's bound
to happen more and i was like obviously
when i was walking with adam it didn't
happen and then i was like by myself one
day walking around and i was like oh my
god what's happening it's a whole little
different vibe yes
so that that was my question like what
is this what you say there's not really
a way to put a blanket answer on that
i feel like just being you're being
yourself you know so cliche to say but
it's true don't seem thirsty don't seem
like you really want it so much you know
but like if you if that's the area in
your life that you're trying to pick up
girls which at the bar which i don't
feel like it's like necessarily the best
place like i feel like
maybe like
not the gym is hard too because it's
like a lot of girls don't want to be
talked to at the gym at all they're like
they're like they don't have their
makeup on they just want to do their
thing guys always try to come over and
mansplain like how to use machines and
[ __ ] so that's kind of tough but like
maybe if you're like in a workout class
somewhere where you're like
a collective place meeting where you're
not trying to meet the person or like a
friend of a friend but also if you meet
someone in a place where it's like let's
say you're like interested in yoga or
you're interested in golf or whatever it
is like then you'll find someone
somewhere where maybe they have a
similar interest with you so like then
you're kind of like already weeding out
some people you know like so it's all
about your presence and a lot of dudes
are like i don't wanna i'm gonna go to a
bar and hang out with a girl oh you know
what she ended up sucking but you went
to a bar yeah you went to a [ __ ] bar
not everybody that drinks is bad but go
to the like you said go to the golf
course
go something you like and and i feel
like kind of weird answering these sort
of questions because i obviously have
been off the market for like six years
and i feel like i don't know how to play
the game so much anymore
in general like if some man
you're not gonna be like you know what
take my number you're not going to do
that anymore i know but if a dude came
back like get the [ __ ] away from me
versus i'm actually i'm i'm with
somebody
giving my number to dudes like on the
street before who will come up to me in
a very nice approachable way and like
ask me a question and just been really
honest like hey you caught my attention
you're really beautiful i'd really like
to take you out for a drink sometime can
i have your number
like
okay
you know that was good here's my number
wild confidence to do that yeah
he was really good looking but then
after i gave him my number he
immediately started texting me really
weird serial killer type [ __ ] and i was
like okay blocked but i thought i had i
thought i had my senses on right that
day but no being a girl not for me
i told rosie
oh
my god it would suck i told rosie i was
uh
i was that i'm not gonna say exactly
where because what if i was out of place
and this lady i i don't even think i
told you this lady was she's nice she's
a nice lady
i'm not a little kid but i'm also not
super old she was about 55 60 super nice
lady pretty lady
she would not stop making me feel
uncomfortable
she made me feel so uncomfortable and i
brought you only my wife like 16 times
just and didn't stop that didn't that
didn't stop anything
like oh yeah i kept touching like
you know what i'm saying so i'm just an
out-of-shape guy
that doesn't happen often imagine being
a pretty girl walk into the car every
dude
at all times
is a threat yeah i know i don't know
everything she's hitting on you because
you're heavier and she thought like oh
he has to want me like
do you think that she was she was doing
some [ __ ] like that to you or like he
must have a fantasy about older women or
something i don't know no i mean just
shooting her shot i think like like
i mean
people are nice to like lady girls are
nice to me all the time because probably
because i'm very nice but she was being
really excited but she was being
aggressive i was like oh [ __ ] so now you
feel like i have to take my girl with me
everywhere i go no i always explain but
hey no thank you i said wife 30 times
but it usually probably works how many
dudes are not if you've got an
aggressive woman coming at you are like
oh she probably felt like terrible after
like that didn't work i'm getting older
she must have thought
her feelings and usually she gets the
two and the dudes are gone you don't
want to hurt people's feelings like no
stop get like you don't want her i'll
hurt some feelings i don't care but to
an older lady
dudes go crazy though because you're in
the situation where this dude's like
hitting on you you're just scared and if
you like if then like you disrespect him
or something you might go psychotic oh
yeah i remember um when adam had his
shop on melrose i was like it was kind
of hard to park there and i was like
driving around looking for parking and
some guy was straight up just following
me and his car is trying to holler at me
and i'm like you're following me like
what makes you think that i'm gonna
actually
want to to be with you you're scaring me
yeah you know
i'm scared right now and then it's like
when you're like hey leave me alone
they're like [ __ ] you [ __ ] and you're
like jesus
but then again i think he's just the
type of dude because i yeah could never
see a situation where i go
oh you don't like me [ __ ] you i would
never like
in my soul like it's not there
and plus he his daughter just turned 14.
so he's all like so what do you think
about this like what do you do about
guys doing this all right i'm going to
talk to her
so he's like on the hunt of like get the
[ __ ] yeah it's done yeah
and it does start happening at that age
like where guys are just like they don't
i don't know how old you are and they're
just gonna start like because i would
walk um to middle school and high school
and stuff and that's when it started
happening it's like hey you're like
whisper on the street you're like i'm
just trying to go to class i'm like in
the seventh grade yeah it always changed
my opinion on a dude when i like you
know she looks young oh you don't look
that young
we're not good friends anymore yeah i
don't know if i can hang out with you if
you can't figure out how old she might
be
just off limits yeah right away yeah
but i feel like i feel like it's i don't
know i mean if you if you just look at
someone maybe you can't tell but like i
was getting my nails done yesterday and
i just knew the girls next to me were in
high school i could just tell from like
the first sentence they said yeah just
the way the girls were talking to each
other i was like they're young like
they're kids you know it's kind of
usually easy to tell if you really pay
attention i think if you're not a creep
it's easy to tell
if you don't care then it's not if you
don't give a [ __ ]
and you would have said it anyway
it's doesn't matter
people are creepy um so
i have a question i know we went on a
far tangent
you said right when you pulled up oh i
grew up around here you grew up so
burbank area where did you grow up where
did you go to school i lived in glendale
like the south of glendale my whole life
um went to glendale high
so like
you know i know that this is the area of
the world that i know like better than
anywhere else obviously like very heavy
armenian proud population pretty
conservative population um
it's like my family is not that like
traditional in their
beliefs you know it's not like
i wasn't the
girl that was never allowed to go to a
sleepover or never allowed to leave your
house and stuff like that
but when my before my parents divorced
and my dad still lived with us like you
know like i wasn't allowed to watch mtv
even like what age is this
um i think they stopped living together
when i was like in middle school seventh
or eighth grade but like if i was
watching i should i always give the
example of boy meets role because i just
have like a million memories of watching
that show but i was always like okay
cory and topanga please don't kiss them
this episode please please because if my
dad sees you that they kiss then i'm
gonna be in trouble and like i'm not
gonna be allowed to watch tv anymore so
like i would always get excited when i
would go to my cousin's house because
they had the show that had to grab the
channel that had degrassi and i was like
yeah let's watch it here you know it's
like very
super sheltered but like
your parents cared yeah they like
especially with like sex and like
boyfriends and stuff like
you know are you an only child no i was
the oldest child but my sister's only
like a year younger than me it's just
the two oh so if you have two pretty
daughters yeah of course he's going to
be like no don't be watching boy means
well it's a weird thing because it's
like regular music this is the sexed out
rap it's like i don't want to be some
dad that you have to hide what music you
like in front of me but also it's weird
to listen yeah and you know what the
words really mean and you don't think
she really does like she might
understand a little bit makes you feel
old real quick yeah yeah either way
yeah like it's not cool like now with
tick tock it's like now they're dancing
to it on twitter
yeah
euphoria ruined before i ruined youth
i watched it the other day and went no
you had never seen it before i wat for
the first time i watched about a month
ago and the first episode i thought i
was 15 year old girl
my whole thought process is now ruined
when you said that i was like you're
[ __ ] and then i went is your daughter
watching yes but i don't know if i'd let
her watch this one man it gets a little
while it makes drug use slightly
glorified because i was doing heavy
drugs in high school
without that show well you were in a
[ __ ] drug zone that's different yeah
okay yes but i feel like it's like
different because i had the opportunity
to do drugs in high school like you know
the rave scene had started like around
my junior senior year so like all the
insomniac events were still here and all
my girlfriends were going and doing
molly and like i always drove and i
always stayed sober and just like
i just i was too afraid i didn't really
want to and i would since i was sober
would go i would see like what everyone
looked like
you know they look crazy
yeah and then and then i was like
shocked because i was there and i'm like
i'm only 17 but i felt pretty wise i was
like they capped off all the water in
the um the water fountains at the events
because they wanted to buy water and
like these [ __ ] people are dehydrated
on the floor here and they have to like
go wait in line to get water and it's
like ten dollars and so i was just like
at that age like really scared i was
like what if i need you know
you're being smart you want to live i
feel like i didn't let myself be a kid
sometimes i did end up trying drugs like
once i got to college but even then i
was like
like i liked molly but i was always here
to weed weed [ __ ] me up i can't do i
can't smoke
i can't do weed i was gonna say i mean
that's fine as long as you know what
like marty's never done hard drugs
before uh-huh love it [ __ ] it's the
coolest thing like you're an adult
you've never done hard drugs [ __ ] yeah
good [ __ ]
because you made it through you you knew
what you wanted
you're sitting there i'll be the
designated driver [ __ ] that i'll give
you a draw that's great i think it's
great yeah i just i don't know i guess i
was always paranoid of dying from a
really young age
what if i was parent of having a child
so that should be that's why i was most
scared of my whole life just trying not
to get girls pregnant well uh where i'm
from at the highest
teenage pregnancy rate in the country oh
wow so ever if you don't have a kid by
16 17 like you're not gonna have kids
[ __ ] let me graduate first april's best
friend just got pregnant my wife april
her best friend she's in her 30s and
it's like it seems so
long but it's like that's actually kind
of how you're supposed to do it wait a
little bit let yourself yeah i mean
where i live and and i go to like the
mommy and me groups with my daughter and
she's like
20 months
i'm like the youngest mom in the room a
lot of times i'm 31. so in some circles
though the women are waiting longer to
have kids and they're maybe using ivf or
whatever but in some places you know
obviously having a baby at a younger age
is more normalized but i feel like
especially now that i have a kid
if i could have gotten pregnant at 50
and lived to be 100
i would have done it because it is so
different and it is so hard we just went
to tennessee for a week with my daughter
and it's supposed to be like a vacation
yeah and i feel like i need a vacation
from that because it was exhausting to
do stuff you're like
nothing will ever be relaxing again no
just accept that always going to be
worrying about someone other than
yourself forever that's why i'm afraid
yeah you're afraid you should be afraid
i don't want a pet i don't want anything
because i know myself
i will go 100 and like and then my work
legs because i'm not going to put work
first i already know that
well you need a good support system for
sure
yeah
yeah i'm not ready for that that's okay
yeah you know what i'm not going gonna
sit here and convince you to have kids
oh yeah yeah no i think it's amazing
that you guys have that's like a
testament coming from where you come
from to you and rosie being together
building up all this stuff and not
deliberately not having kids is the
things right because me and her so
selfish with our time but do you think
it's made you more too paranoid
like do you think she's going to get
pregnant one day and you're going to be
like oh i don't know i don't know
so
at this point
like no give me five years because we're
about to buy a house we always say like
how are we gonna buy a house in the pool
there's a bunch of naked [ __ ] out
everywhere we're all doing [ __ ]
drugs and doing cool stuff
hold on like my kid is inside
i haven't had that time yet
i mean if you're still living that life
and you're not no we don't do drugs
i'm just saying like how what if yeah if
we want to do that [ __ ]
we're not there yet we haven't got to
have a lot of fun yet adam and i like
partied a ton when we first started
dating and then at some point we just
naturally stopped honestly it's like
stopped caring
new years of 2018 going into 2019 we
like got so [ __ ] up and we just like
it's not like we woke up and decided
like we're never going to do this again
we just kind of stopped partying
and then in
2019 we like instead of going out for
halloween we decided to take his nephews
trick-or-treating and we were like what
the [ __ ] are we doing we're like already
acting like we're parents we're not
having fun so let's just have a kid
already yeah but also i think you you
don't have a traditional job you don't
have to go i have to go punch in
so i think taking them on on they are to
halloween what a change yeah yeah i'm
doing parents [ __ ] this is cool yeah i
know i've always loved kids i've always
worked with kids so for me i was like i
always knew i was gonna be a mom it was
just a matter of when and we had bought
our house like you know
i guess july 2019 so by by the time we
decided to get pregnant it was like we
had our foundations
in a way you know we're kind of like
this house feels a little empty having a
kid when you're 20 and broke is so much
fun
it's a goddamn tundra blizzard outside
and you got flat tires and [ __ ] and you
gotta get to work so just barney's that
happy you bypassed all that [ __ ]
i like don't know you well so i just
realized that you were contracting sorry
yeah marty had kids young as hell all of
them
so
that's marty's life yeah but like my mom
had my sister at 15 16 then me at 18. my
dad was like 18 19.
so i've watched people struggle my whole
life and that's what scared me to death
yeah were you raised by your grandma
for sure yeah i was raised by my grandma
too even though my mom had me at 31 it
was like you know
it's hard like what did your parents do
my mom was like banker when i was
younger and then my dad's an electrician
okay so both parents work so you you
weren't struggling growing up especially
out here um we had like support from my
uncle like we lived in a house that was
owned by my uncle we never like owned
our own house we were like we did we did
okay you know i never like was like yo
you can't have that but i i wasn't like
ballin i didn't have any like super
fancy things you went to college though
they
i went to college but i went to college
with mostly with grants and i had like
maybe five thousand dollars worth of
loans when i graduated so i was in a way
better position than the average person
when i graduated and then i moved back
here and i was like
driving for uber while i was studying
for the gre
took the test got into usc for grad
school and then was like okay this is
really expensive and i'm not really sure
if i want to do it or if i'm just like
kind of following the path that i think
people are expecting me to follow
because i was like the first in my
family to go to college and stuff like
that and that's when i was like okay
let's pause let's not you know take out
a hundred thousand dollars with the
loans when we don't have any money what
were you going for like what's gre i had
my um undergrad in psych and the the
grad school was going to be like a year
for industrial and organizational
psychology and it's kind of like
psychology of the workplace you're like
trying to figure out how to make the
workplace more efficient like a lot of
human resources type so you would be the
human resources person yeah but it was
like i was picking it not because i was
like passionate about it i don't feel
like a lot of people go into psychology
and are like i want to make the
workplace more efficient they mostly go
into it because they want to like help
people and i felt like i was kind of
like selling out in a way because it's
like the field that in psychology that
you can kind of make the most money in
but i wasn't really sure that i actually
wanted it in the first place but i
i didn't know any other way like i
always did really well in school and i
just progressed and progressed and
progressed and i thought like i would
continue with academia and get my phd
and yada yada then i was like no no i
don't actually think i want this i need
to like actually stop for a second and
figure out what i want to do not get all
that extra debt the extra debt the extra
work um was it actually going to make me
happy i don't know
but you're happy now i'm happy i'm
pretty happy
the question i had was you went up to
school up north first and then went back
to school down here you went to school
twice no i didn't go to school twice so
i went up to
up to santa cruz i got my undergrad up
there and then i moved back here because
i was just like i didn't know what i was
going to keep doing in santa cruz i love
santa cruz i honestly would love to buy
a house there's my questions santa cruz
best [ __ ] place that's where i went
every weekend growing up oh really my
sister moved there so i at 18
from 15 to about 22 i was there every
weekend my sister you go to the
boardwalk well my sister you know
pacific avenue yeah yeah you know street
light that big wrecker come yeah that's
my sister and i don't know if it's there
anymore is it still there it's still
there but i think they're not doing very
well sucks well i was just there with
adam in january
a lot of [ __ ] is closed down so yeah
specific my sister used to work at the
cookie company right there yes pcc yeah
oh damn you already know what's up
had like nicknames for things so just
call it pcc so yeah pacific cook company
and then street light my sister would
work there so i would go to um
i would go to the catalyst all the time
for shows so i lived up there basically
every weekend before we could try we'd
all like pitch in and go to santa cruz
to go to the boardwalk sometimes but it
was mainly just to go to concerts so i
was gonna ask what is your favorite
place to go in santa cruz since you know
what's your favorite chill spot in santa
cruz ooh my favorite chill spot like you
and your friends honestly are you doing
something i always like going up to
campus i like was on a certain part of
campus where you have like a view of the
entire city and
well no it's like we called it the knoll
it's like overlooking the field like the
um i haven't been not the soccer field
but like
it's where you see the prettiest view i
think um and then i like bookshop santa
cruz i like all the local [ __ ] there
like here i feel like if i want to do
something and go to like a nice
bookstore there are nice spots but
they're probably more like out in silver
lake and stuff and that feels like
silver like is santa cruz to me yeah
the first time i drove here what the
[ __ ] is this like little bungalows and
little tiny houses on top of each other
yeah no i i was uh
gonna ask i used to go to the river
mouth that's why you should smoke weed
non-stop oh okay you know right right
where it's uh you could see the
boardwalk to your right yeah yeah it's
the santa cruz the clothing company like
is that from santa cruz yeah yeah
coincidence okay yeah santa cruz is from
there the o'neills oh neil o'neil
yeah there's actually a lot of companies
from out there i can't think about the
owner lived out there too right yeah
that fat ass house and the rock liz
right there on the sea cliff too i love
my time in santa cruz it's like the best
time of my life i was so happy to be
able to take parker there
it's so dope yeah it's just i love it so
much i feel very cleansed when i come
back i don't know what it is about santa
cruz i love it so i always tell you i
love santa cruz it's not like a super
small town there's like 50 000 plus
people but it feels very small town
there and i really like that like i grew
up here but when i went there i was like
okay maybe this is more my speed yeah
it's like it's like here where do you
irv it's like irvine it's like clean but
it's still a beach
well supervised on the beach more like i
like big would you call it big sur is my
spot by your house yeah whatever buy
your house uh laguna beach that's right
yeah beach is very nice area it's super
nice but santa cruz is a little more
like laguna beach and you could probably
buy wheat yeah
it's a hippie-fied version yeah it's
cool i like it they're not they're no
hippies in laguna beach okay so question
you go to school up there you go to
school down here you decide
you're not it's not for you you're done
i don't go to school down here i apply
and i get in and i think part of me like
just wanted to know that i can get into
grad school and i was like okay i
already did that but i'm not going to go
um oh i thought yeah i thought that you
were going to school actively still down
here no no i i just got accepted but i
think oh so
let me get it [ __ ] you yeah i mean it
was a really hard program to get into so
i got it i know that i can get in the
parents post
uh i don't think they were really pissed
because
you know it was expensive and there was
no way that they could help me and
that's like a ton of money so i think
they understood like why i didn't pursue
it yeah
um but i think they were confused when i
graduated college because i mean i went
to college in 2009 so right when the
recession hit and then i graduated
they're kind of like well you're the
first person in our family to go to
college like why don't you have like a
multi-million dollar job now you know
because i just didn't really understand
are you first generation here yeah
oh so they automatically think oh
american dream you went to [ __ ]
university you're gonna save us all you
went to college you know your parents
are medium yeah oh gotcha okay gotcha
okay okay so you're down here you decide
i'm that's not for me
what is your next step you say you start
doing well you were already doing uber
you said yeah i was like
nannying for some families doing uber um
that was pretty much it like just i had
i had like since i had the psych degree
and i'd worked with kids with um special
needs mostly with autism i'd like
started working with a family and
basically like helping their kid but
also watching their kid doing stuff like
that and then when i was there
i mean i loved it it was definitely very
rewarding work like
being able to teach a kid who has
trouble like how to ride a bike and
stuff like that like it really like
meant a lot to me but you know you're
mostly talking to children all day and
like so you don't feel very stimulated
and i had graduated college i felt like
it left a very stimulating environment
and then all of a sudden i'm like
i don't know
didn't feel like i was like going
anywhere so at the time
i like
just started interning with this company
called arsenic they like
i don't even know tv yes like i don't
even know how to describe like what they
do because also what they've done has
changed over the years but i like knew
this model girl and she like took me to
the house one day for like an event and
then i was just like hey like do you
guys need any help with anything like
i'll help and so i like kind of worked
for free for a couple weeks and they're
like okay you're good enough we'll hire
you and so i worked for them and we were
basically like helping models blow up
through the snapchat like girls that
would you know i don't even know what
we're doing but i basically did outreach
all day to girls and would get them to
come to the house and create content
it's like very early snapchat very early
instagram
and when i was there
that's when it kind of dawned on me like
okay well
i
i'm not any less pretty than some of
these girls so why don't i kind of try
to do the same thing
and um
you see the formula yeah exactly and so
by the time that i left there had like a
good amount of followers and i didn't
leave until i knew i had like a plan and
back then was when i kept getting
questions about like so do you have a
private snapchat cause i started posting
like
they're
back then they were scary to post just
photos of me in my bikini on instagram
because obviously no one that i knew in
my personal life was really doing things
like that back then so it felt very
taboo but i had been doing things like
that on my instagram and that's when
people would message me and so it kind
of became like very obvious that if i
did decide to leave and make the plunge
and make a private snapchat that i was
going to be making pretty good money and
be able to support myself and that's
when i left and that was my first month
i made like 30k or whatever and it was
like
it didn't really believe it at that
moment i was like okay save all this
money because you're never going to be
able to have it again like you know
you're just so you just have a huge
scarcity mindset it's not like i went
and bought a bunch of stuff i like went
and found a place to rent that was like
reasonably priced but then you know that
was september 2016 and
now it's you know 2022 and i'm still
doing it and i'm i've progressed in it
and also the landscape's changed there's
been different things that have happened
that have made it easier to make money
but i i still am in disbelief and i
still don't treat it like like it can't
be taken away from me at any second
because i know it can you know youtube
only fans all these platforms that we
all rely on you i know we share uh
instagram getting deleted in common with
each other so um
i'm grateful and i'm not like okay i'm
set you know i don't really still like
that yeah exactly of course some people
get the first million dollars go off
i'm chilling yeah no no no a million
dollars is not a lot especially when you
have to pay half of it to the state
especially just trying to live in
california and buy a house in southern
california a million dollars you are
broke a million dollars is not a very
nice house in los angeles
i know it's a fixer-upper you gotta go
every day and a million is nothing out
here it hurts my heart it hurts it is
really sad like sometimes we wanna like
move and i'm like well if we sell our
house and move we're not going to be
able to afford the house we want because
just the houses have gone up so much in
the last couple years so yeah ellie
you're not really rich in la you can
move somewhere else
um so
for everyone out there wondering this is
more like i'm thinking more of a fan
like if i was a fan i wanted to ask a
question
what is your day
random a regular day that has a work in
it you know how's work in it yeah
because you know that's a content like
you know what today i'm not filming [ __ ]
i'm calling my home i'm gonna do
something i'm gonna go watch a movie i'm
gonna do something because you're
working there is no schedule yeah i mean
when there is but you try to stick to it
it's damn near impossible especially
when you work with other people you
can't make sure that they're
like you and showed up exactly on
[ __ ] time not everybody does so
what's your day on a workday or non-work
day work day work day i usually wake up
hang i'm i wake up pretty early it's
like 6 30 seven yeah because you're
i'm a mom so you know me and the kid we
hang out we like play whatever i feed a
breakfast for a couple hours um
i go work out come back shower get in
hair makeup my least favorite part of
the [ __ ] day i hate sitting there and
not actually actively doing anything but
i can't use my hands i just have to sit
there whatever hair and makeup is an
essential part of having a set day and
then i'll go to the studio house that i
bought um
and that's where we'll probably shoot
like
two maybe three plug talks and then
you know watch take a shower wash my
face come home and do bedtime and that's
like oh your whole oh the filming is all
day
um well it's like a five or six hour day
that's how many we'll do like two or
three plug talks in that much time but i
create my schedule so that i'm always
home to do bedtime no oh and bedtime
could could be like that time it's
really early it's like seven seven
thirty it's your whole day no seven
seven thirty and then it's like you know
by the time i put her to bed it's like i
have to go to bed pretty early because i
have to wake up really early with her
again so the last couple hours of my day
i'm
probably scrolling or doing legos or
trying to read and then keep picking up
my phone mom life you know
yeah do you think the stigma of like
girls that do porn is probably going to
change over the next couple of years
from where it's like
the first the stigma you'd have
overgrown good point in the past might
be she got daddy issues she's got
problems she's kind of forced into this
but now it's like
maybe moving forward with only fans it's
like
college degree yeah i'm doing this
because i it's super lucra it's a
business decision yeah i think you can
you're gonna i mean you already see it
but you're gonna see more and more
stories of different types of ways that
girls spell into the industry because a
lot of the girls we interview on plug
talk they like started doing traditional
porn but usually they're getting into
the industry in one or two ways it's
like they needed money and they started
stripping and then they met a guy or a
guy got them into it or they needed
money so they started camming and then
camming led them into porn but i think
more and more it's going to be like yeah
i got my law degree and then i decided
[ __ ] this [ __ ] i don't want to read all
these books i feel drained and depressed
i'm going to do an only fans i have big
tits you know like
and i and i think that like perfect
people are always like how are you going
to explain this to your kid i think by
the time that my kid is in high school
she might have another kid in her class
whose parent hasn't only fans you know
100 i and i think maybe it's not only
fans anymore and like probably by the
time i kiss in high school like i'm not
going to be doing this [ __ ] anymore you
know um
but yeah i think it's definitely getting
less stigmatized i think of course there
are people who still see it in a really
twisted old school medieval way but um
the the movement is progressing where it
is only fans like it's an app right no
it's not an app it's not allowed to be
in the app store because it has 18 plus
content on it oh okay it's just a
website does
do sites like that where the the person
can just stream themselves do those are
those bigger than like regular
old-school porn sites i'm actually not
sure i think that because only fans well
no it's hard to say i feel like maybe
only fans has more traffic because when
you think about it they have tons of
users i forgot how many users they
accrued over the pandemic but it's like
all of these different like influencers
and many influencers are driving all
this traffic versus like a traditional
porn company has like their email list
and their traffic from however you know
maybe two decades that they've been in
industry or whatever it is but i feel
like it's got to be more coming from
influencers i'm just but i'm just
getting it
has to be more right like if we all
drove our traffic to the same website
but the thing is like there is no
explorer page on only fans so you can
only get discovered on only fans by your
by someone finding your name like
someone in your audience looking me up
or finding my strong fan base comes into
play yeah but like they have no explorer
pages
by design because they don't want the
like people that don't want to see porn
on there it's like well it's like
they're like
i think when you sign up as a user who's
not creating content i think that it
might like suggest to you some people to
follow at the bottom
but as far as i know like there is no
like main page translated
but like i don't think it's it's not
like with twitch where i feel like you
can click like a category of things you
want to watch and i'll show you who's
doing what you know what i mean i think
part of that has to probably be because
there's so much 18 plus like because
they would probably only want like the
safer work stuff on the front page and a
lot of this is well a perfect example a
lot of this is
a couple
right correct people couples on only
fans correct like
because you see a girl that's an adult
star
and she's in scenes with different
people different
a lot of the only fans right
there with their partner correct making
content i think a a lot of girls are you
know having sex with random people but i
would i would guess that most people are
having sex with the same person even if
they're making it seem like they're not
because it's like you know role play is
a common thing so you can like pretend
someone's your uber driver or your
gardener or whatever it is and make a
scene with them and then they can't see
their face so it doesn't matter but like
it's a lot more practical um
to just have sex with the same person
every time you know um obviously if
you're in the industry and you know a
lot of like performers who do
professional porn and you can trust them
then it's easy to go work with multiple
different people booking somebody as a
girl hey oh yeah i need a dude to have
sex with like no no stop reward that
[ __ ] do not say it like that is it only
live streaming or do you have like no no
i've never live stream on my only fan do
you create the content and you upload it
youtube either to a feed or you can send
it as a message to someone and then they
can purchase it in the messages gotcha
okay and that's where the that's what my
friend told me the majority of her money
is made in the messages yeah it's like a
different model for everyone i i feel
like mine is equal like messages
slash subscription but a lot of people
will price their only fans as free so
then the only money that they really
make is from people purchasing a video
individually
hey what's up guys just taking a moment
to talk about one of our long time
sponsors and this is manscaped before we
get into it guys as always go to
www.mance
forward slash yola that's going to get
you 20 off of your entire order plus
free shipping with that being said let's
get straight into this and what are we
getting into sweaty sack summer i don't
write this all right just want to let
you know that is their actual tagline
for manscaped sweaty sac summer you guys
already know sweaty balls not fun sweaty
balls covered in hair probably a lot
worse did you know that manscaped also
makes boxer briefs if you didn't know
that go to manscape.com and check it out
so right now if you're shocked that
we're talking about underwear because
you didn't know manscape sells underwear
well here's some more stuff that they
sell they got ball toner ball deodorant
a 4.0 lawnmower which is the king of
kings they got the nose hair trimmer
weed whacker they there's so much that
list goes on everything just boils down
to keep that dick clean don't be a dirty
[ __ ] and go to manscape.com forward
slash yolo use 20 off plus free shipping
so with that vulgarness of an ad read
let's go right back into this wholesome
episode
now do you have any advanced knowledge
on like a metaverse like
porn
it's going to be a metaverse strip club
where tonight uh i will be
dancing at so and so strip club in the
metaverse if someone wanted me to do
something in the metaverse i guess i
would do it it's probably going to be a
big thing i guess if the metabolism is
really big i could imagine
you're going to go anywhere
all right i would hate that i feel like
those goggles are going to make me
carsick they do make me that's why
that's why i don't do it but i loved vr
fighting game i got so sick
it's not funny yeah i can't do it i i
would definitely not be able to do it
did you see during the pandemic
in new york they had this like glass
they had a bus one side was glass they
had like four poles and they were
strippers and they were driving up to
people's houses because you can't have
contact so there was through the glass
so there was a mobile strip but how do
you tip them with a vendor through the
thing inside
so that's pretty genius it's pretty
genius so could you imagine going uh
let's go to spearmint right now
oh my favorite adult actress is going to
be there
yes
and
you say
like say you're at a strip club a dancer
can only really dance on one person yeah
with that it just connects like oh you
just gave a loud dance to 1600 people
and they all tipped you at once it's
kind of like camming but it it probably
feels more pleasurable for the viewer in
that that they can see and they they
went into a place and they feel like
they're touching your ass but they're
not isn't that insane there's something
dude like
people are gonna be [ __ ] living in
there oh for sure people are gonna live
in there yeah i mean i camped for a
little bit it wasn't for me but there
was definitely like returning customers
who were there every single day you know
all day long like they're there and
build a relationship with any of these
dudes like yo how's how's work
um yes some of them but like to the big
tippers who were like consistently in my
chat room and were like making my day
worth me being online but that's why i
didn't like it because i like efficiency
i want to like make a piece of content
and then sell it and then with with
passive yeah exactly but with camming it
was like it was good because it's like
going to work at that point it was kind
of like fun and social for like the
first couple hours i was like very
bubbly very excited but then after that
you kind of just like
draining and like you have to stay on i
mean i really give it to the twitch
streamers and every cam girl who's on
all day and is able to make it fun and
exciting for themselves because you have
to be performing constantly yeah you're
a performer literally if you call it
adult performer it's it's still but even
for like regular people who are just
streaming video games or whatever it's
like you can't just play and be silent
you have to be engaging with your
audience it's crazy i see some of the
setups people have amazing i give it up
to them i just tried my twitch set it
took it took forever there's so much
that goes into this it's a full-time job
it doesn't really feel like it's
something that's easy for just anyone to
go into if you want a good setup i feel
like there's so like i'm like how to do
a twitch setup you look it up and then
there's like 80 words you don't
understand so much different than even
just yeah just have a friend come in
basically yeah and then on top of it you
do this big ass setup and now it's like
i got a freestyle talk
that's my easiest thing like freestyle
talk how many hours you need yeah
everything else i could not set up a
twitch stream so are you gonna be doing
twitch now yeah i have a twitch i just
it was so much to to keep up with i
didn't have cool
over i just didn't i think it could be
better
yeah i bought the whole thing and it's
just sitting there it's behind that red
car you should you should sell it as
like a twitch stream just tell us oh we
are going to do two weeks
oh for sure i've just uh i haven't set
it up fully we've been working we've
been got it we've been doing so much
he's been building stuff
you got to do like a consistent schedule
too because that's like every wednesday
i was thinking because we film on
tuesdays uh usually every tuesday after
the podcast for three hours i'll be on
twitter yeah exactly just trying to
think of something consistent because we
always use a comparison you know sunday
night oh maybe you don't know
simpsons came on sunday night your
parents let you watch the simpsons uh no
i didn't watch the simpsons but i know
what they are adam always makes simpsons
references that i don't understand but
he learned a lot from that show
the tattoo right lisa simpson yes but
that tattoo is a trick it's a little
little peeps
and all the characters okay so every
sunday at eight it comes on right so i
always thought like
that's what got me excited oh it's
sunday yes i have something so for
twitch or pick a day like oh what time
what's the day he's tweeting streaming
tonight that's how i want to be you have
to be a part of someone's routine i know
i'm like sad when i don't have the show
that i'm watching like just euphoria was
a good one before he was actually really
[ __ ] shot so
everything about it's good
off topic
what shows are you watching currently if
you say you're watching stuff i'm not
watching anything right now i did this
oh actually i finished ozark but i am
adam's like the worst person to watch tv
with okay i want to sit there and watch
every [ __ ] episode until we finish
watching it and he
first of all he smokes a blunt before we
watch anything he's so bad at following
plot lines he's like honestly i'm not
gonna lie i have no idea what's going on
so then we have to like pause and i have
to explain it to him or he falls asleep
and so we have to re-watch the episode
again the next night and then we don't
and i'm like dude i'm just gonna [ __ ]
watch the show without you but the show
we're trying to watch is the boys are
you watch the boys oh that [ __ ] comes on
tomorrow new episode every friday i
can't [ __ ] i'm like on episode one
and a half because of adam of this new
season
but i'm so [ __ ] annoyed so i have to
like go home tonight and maybe try to
watch myself i'm just waiting for days
to go so [ __ ] friday comes i can
watch this [ __ ] show the boys is so
damn good i'm stuck on it so good i'm so
in this new season
give me the loose you told me about that
one if it's
superheroes if they were treated that's
right
if superman was lebron james but what
did he do behind doors closed doors yeah
and in 2022 there's like you know their
social media really matters all their
social numbers yeah like marvel movies
are just them on camera
doing a plotline yeah like about yes
yeah it's like bts it's really really
well great show dude but what about
all-time favorite like all-time favorite
series ooh top two or three
gosh that's tough i i feel like i would
put euphoria on on one of those three
really really good really engaging and
like did you watch the whole thing yeah
there were moments where
i forgot i was watching a show and i had
chills and i was like gonna cry fully
and like fully immersed in it and i felt
like i wasn't there
uh so that's definitely up there i love
that show all time is tough for me but
succession i'm really into and ozark was
really good too he's on ozark i stopped
at season two i haven't i haven't caught
up yet
laura linney's amazing
no i'm still uh i'm still behind she the
girl with the curly blond hair no the
mom
she's incredible
um but i feel like i've been listening
to podcasts more what do you listen to
and what um
do you know dax shepard's podcast
armchair expert i haven't watched it but
jack sheppard's hilarious that fool from
uh
let's go to prison i've heard that yeah
so i actually so i was a big new girl
fan and uh
max greenfield from new girl and so
that's what got me into the show and i
was like [ __ ] it i'm gonna go back five
years and just start from the beginning
and there's so many episodes so that's
why i'm kind of like binging those right
now nice yeah i uh i'm like you like can
we just [ __ ] finish this [ __ ]
tonight because i'm gonna forget what
happens if i wait too long and then i
have to watch those youtube recap videos
i really respect the people who do those
they work really hard they work so hard
yeah like i'm saying they won't say what
it is but i was watching there was this
youtuber getting [ __ ] on and go whoever
made the video put so much time and
effort over latest transitions for
somebody you hate yes
and they do so much research so much i'm
the kind of person who's like really
interested and really engaged in a book
or a movie or whatever but if you ask me
about it three and a half hours later i
am not gonna forget it remember exactly
how the story went and so that's why i
really respect people who are able to
connect all the dots and all the seasons
yeah remember names
yeah i'm like it's hard people do movie
reviews i feel like they must have been
like english majors or something i don't
know i don't know i wasn't good in
school so
i was good in school and i still can't
remember [ __ ] i forget everybody's names
immediately yeah you do i remember once
or whatever that's about it that's it i
mean
as far as tv people people yeah i mean
i'm watching the boys but if you ask me
the character's name i don't [ __ ]
know
huey
yeah in real life i'll know but in the
show i couldn't tell you the names of
everybody i know one guy's name is
homelander done that's true i know that
guy's name done
that's all i know um before i get way
off topic real quick
a dude doing only fans is that worth it
for guys i've had multiple i i answer a
lot of my dm's
and say i'm with i posted a picture with
a certain girl that does only she's a
super popular only fan she's mean
rosie's friend
we posted the whole picture we were
hanging out and i just got flooded with
questions
so one of the questions i got was as a
dude is it worth getting only fans i
know one guy that does only fans and he
crushes that [ __ ] i think it's the one
arena where a girl is most likely gonna
make more oh for sure but i feel like
guys um if they have like a good gimmick
or like a good hook and uh they are you
know a big dick good looking good
performer
um and they're able to collaborate with
girls who
that's what they're already pretty
successful then they could probably be
pretty successful um
but it's i feel like it is kind of
harder to sell yourself because
and you you're gonna have to be
comfortable with having like probably a
gay audience because i think a lot of
the guys
yeah i think a lot of the guys that i
know who do have only fans like those
the people who are messaging them those
people who are like suggesting content
from them so if you do want to pursue it
like you're going to have to be okay
with like chatting with people who are
you know the same sex as you who want
your content yeah
i mean that's i thought 90 of it was i
got to be honest
if you're okay with like just waving
your dick around the camera like be okay
with whoever's working
like how does that translate for a dude
just oh i was thinking like what do you
do as a guy it's funny because like
you're not really allowed to do this on
only fans anymore like you're not
allowed to use non-sex objects for
penetration like cucumbers and stuff but
like i did see a while ago i don't
follow a lot of male performers but i
followed one and i think he was like
[ __ ] different fruits and it like
looked really crazy oh
yeah people ask for crazy [ __ ] online
man i think people like those
people just like stuff that look
visually appealing or like sound
visually appealing like asmr and like
the way things like you know just
entertaining or satisfying to watch like
i think that there was a trend with
people i don't know what it's called
like
that's blue jing i don't know just like
sitting on cakes and smashing cakes with
their body and stuff like that like
people watch this i see that as a waste
of food that's all i see yeah like damn
man people might think it sounds sexy
but it's it's icky i don't like having
food on me no
is it weird meeting porn fans in real
life
like um
trying to think of the instances where
it happened i mean
i think people think it's weirder than i
think it is like i was walking by myself
in new york and this guy someone was
like hey i love the point he's like i'm
a fan of your content and then he was
like you're youtube like now you're porn
i was like it's okay like you can be a
fan of my content i don't want you to
sit there and describe to me what i do
that you really like yeah but you can be
a fan and you can acknowledge that you
know because i'm making the content
putting it out there and i know why you
know me yeah
i think that's where the creep factor
comes back yeah because you could be a
fan of you and come up and go i love
your stuff
and walk away
yeah or you can i would imagine most
people would be like hey can i get a hug
yeah
you hug and you're like oh get off me
i would imagine most dudes are creeps
like my perception of dudes or dudes are
[ __ ] creeps so like i couldn't
imagine no i feel like i've had really
respectful interactions with people for
the most part um you know when you go to
the porn conventions and people are
drinking and maybe they get a little
close and stuff like that that tends to
be a little weird but it's kind of to be
expected in those environments like
they're very excited to be meeting their
favorite actors and actresses
so yeah sometimes it gets a little heavy
so with being in this field have you i
mean you kind of touched on that
have you really seen how vile some of
these people can get because like you
saying on i don't really like to go
through my dfs
because i mean it's the internet it's a
faceless yeah statement so people get
ballsy i think
i think the things that that are the
most annoying are um
like if i'm on my instagram dms and i
get i don't want to say this because i'm
just gonna get a bunch of it once i
leave here is like uh
sending like photos like you know i know
if i'm on my only fans when i open a dm
like that's kind of a place where i can
expect to see someone's nudity but when
people are just like tweeting it at me
or sending it to my instagram dms i'm
like
i'm not here for this [ __ ] you know did
you think it was gonna work yeah i know
it's like you think i was gonna see your
huge [ __ ] and be like oh my god please
come over right now you know what my
family who gives a [ __ ] about the family
business [ __ ] that get over here yeah i
think those dudes got businesses and
families i don't have anything to do and
go you know what she'll change her life
for me i know she will that's a crazy
statement i feel like maybe some people
get off on like knowing that they're
gonna like creep you out or freak you
out but i do think that like i'm not
speaking for everyone i do think like a
lot of girls like might actually want
that maybe or at least they make it seem
like they do want that like you know
um but if i if i say send me your dick
pic i'm usually saying it'll
like not where i'm taking pictures of my
child and ask you for a [ __ ] dick or
sometimes people will send you like uh
a screenshot from a scene and like do
this do this
like very like some people are very
specific about like what position they
want and stuff like that but like all of
it is welcome on my only fans because
that's like a place where i can expect
to be in the sexual mindset i know what
i'm getting there but when i'm just like
scrolling and looking at like cake
recipes and [ __ ] like
it's a little different i'm on pinterest
mode yeah yeah exactly so do you plan on
like one day the podcast kind of taking
over is that like the long term or are
you not really thinking that far ahead
in terms of like all the different like
channels you have going
i think i'm gonna drive this bus until
the wheels fall off and see where it
takes me i if i really start to like
just not be into it anymore then i could
see myself stopping but i mean i i hope
my podcast does really well and i hope
to like be getting better as a podcaster
that to me is more like a fun passion
project like let's see where this goes
kind of thing because for a long time i
was vlogging on youtube and i did really
like it but it's it's kind of hard for
me to vlog now i'm just like at home a
lot or i'm on set boom boom boom boom
boom life's full now and i should try a
little harder at vlogging but i just
feel so out of touch with it so i'm kind
of trying to like replace that form of
content and like connect with my
audience in this new format um and i do
i love listening to podcasts i do want
to get better at it and stuff but i and
if i could rely on it as like a true
um source of my income in the future
that'd be great but like i've never been
able to rely on youtube or brands or
anything like that just because of the
nature of the other work i do but i mean
if i could that'd be great
yeah the brand deal's got to be tricky i
would imagine yeah on my mom page i get
some stuff like you know some normal
[ __ ] like hair shampoo and stuff like
that but a lot of times it's like um sex
toy companies or you know other
porn brands that want you you're just in
a different lane yeah you you are
basically like no go stay that way
because of what you're doing that's what
that's what happens to us like you say
you get deleted every five seconds yeah
yeah even though it shouldn't be that
way you know they know what you're doing
is you're not posting
your content on instagram it's not like
you're posting full
nudity on instagram so it should be
this way i don't like it when you can do
something and you see someone else doing
it fine you go what the [ __ ] dude what
did i do different then you just start
feeling like what did i am i mean
i just want the rules to be applied the
same to everybody i don't care if you
are
like a really well-known name of a
youtuber or a kardashian or whatever i
want the rules to apply with him to
everyone and i know that's not the world
we live in that's not how it works but
god i saw a girl yesterday she posted
like a fully nude video she's in the
bath and she's like bouncing her butt up
and down in the bath and you can only
you can see her side boob and her full
ass she has no underwear on her video is
like eight million views on instagram
and it just it's just there it's
existing and i'm like are you [ __ ]
kidding me i have a i have like selfies
that could get deleted and i'm like bro
what is so offensive about my birthday
tomorrow
i've been my mom to do this my whole
account remember
and you get so mad
shut the [ __ ] up wait what he's like you
see your mom's nipple as well
kardashian kardashian
no like if you're like a true uh
celebrity i guess i mean you get the
pass shout out to brittany i'm so glad
that she has the freedom to post on her
page as she wants now but she posts like
nudity with like a little tiny [ __ ]
emoji and we're calling it okay and it's
like just let the rules apply because
you you get it i know you guys see adam
like again you post another page same
with me i have deleted so much like
them but them you've gone deleted more
than anyone i know from what he's told
me it's a real issue yeah we're almost
to 30 right now yeah it's not it's it's
crazy but
like you say [ __ ] it i'll just keep
working on keep doing another thing like
you said what's going to replace my
vlogging well you know what let's try it
podcasting it's a passion thing if it
can help me with income maybe i can rely
on it more yeah so you're not just
sitting here like oh spitball what's
going to work it's more of like what can
i like what do i like and how did i turn
it into something
something i could make money off of and
be happy to go do yeah because i mean
there's probably like tons of different
kinds of youtube content that i could
make that would probably get a lot of
views but i like don't want to do it
like you know a lot of girls will do
like sexy clothing hauls and things like
that which i did a little bit back in
the day when i first started but it's
like that doesn't sound like fun to me
or like stimulating enough to me and so
like that's why i'm just making the
content that i want to make but i'm also
in a position where i can make those
decisions you know like i if i decided
to stop making content for a couple
months like i'm not gonna go broke i'm
gonna be fine but i had to like get
there you know so of course how long
have you been making content in total
you said 15 16 right uh since 2016 so
yeah it's like almost six years of
content i guess so it's not overnight
well yeah some people are overnight and
then you
especially a little bit overnight back
in the day but like i kept building and
building and building and building yeah
and um
so yeah i'm just gonna see where this
goes honestly people are always like
what's your five-year plan and i'm like
[ __ ] i don't know i didn't think i would
still be doing this if you asked me five
years ago you know so i don't really
have a plan well you're one of the front
runners of making all your money
completely off of your personality off
of you and what you can produce not just
hey buy this shirt yeah i'm saying like
it's something that you have to do
that's why you're saying there's not
really a schedule um you say a work day
or like a day off yeah that's you have
to ask is it a work day if it is uh how
many hours am i putting in today yeah
when you're running your own business
and like i said you run multiple and you
just started a new show
and you're a parent i'm the only one
here that's not a parent so all these
things on top of that you guys have
another life to take care of yeah but i
mean you have to like i said the support
system it's like i don't do this [ __ ]
all on my own i like
i have an amazing assistant i have an
amazing nanny like obviously i have adam
so
but i'm able to
have those means because of the life i
was able to create for myself and like
for me like i do enjoy having sex i do
enjoy making the content but in the
beginning
i was like oh wait if i make this kind
of money i have the freedom to do what i
want with my time and call the shots for
myself and you know like i was living
the kind of life where i didn't have an
hour to go to the gym you know and so
part of me just wanted that like i just
want to be able to [ __ ] go and put in
time in the gym because that is
something i enjoy you know so that's
really the thing that kind of started
this
but i i really can't believe it's come
this far and obviously adam's big help
for me but he's pushed me a lot he
pushed me to do the podcast thing so
well good i mean you're episode one that
you've shown so far one episode that
i've shown you three so far is it gonna
be an array of guests are you only going
for
um people that you know personally
friends i mean at first i'm definitely
reaching out to people that i know
personally because i don't want to be
like hey do my podcast that's like you
know not that well known if you're like
you know i'll reach for the bigger
guests as i kind of get there but i do
already like i'm lucky because i know a
lot of girls in the industry who are
pretty well known and who are down to be
on it but uh i have adam's gonna be on
as a guest um and i have a another a
couple of other girls that i'm friends
with who are gonna be on but i do want
to reach out to more than just the adult
industry um
there are some mom influencers i have my
eye on that i want to talk to you yeah i
feel like talking about the mom stuff
just comes so much more naturally to me
these days because i'm so immersed in it
it's just the phase of your life yeah
that's what's going on right now like
right now it's podcasting with us it
used to be just selling packs and maybe
it'll be something different yeah yeah
we all evolve into certain different
things that we like
um before we get out here i want to ask
you something we haven't asked this in a
[ __ ] while
so something we do is called who were
you in the 90s and since you are in our
age group i'm third i'm about to be 33
in a couple months so we're we're right
next to each other you're probably gonna
know most of these things i hope so it's
more in 91 so you're good you're good
okay i think you're gonna get it so
basically who were you in the 90s i'm
going to ask you something you pick
between the two
not on your current self on your 90 self
so if you're more you know what i mean
you were a kid in the 90s so you have to
think of all right little me what would
i have done that's okay but it's like
gut answer yes
okay thank you ideally gut answer
usually this stretches into like an hour
but i know because everybody like adam
well we went up for 40 minutes on donkey
kong yeah so i have to pee so i'm not
going to do that
i'll wait we can we can take a little
break too no no no no
have a moment i'm going all right here
we go all right here we go
so here are you in the 90s oh no look
ready vh1 or mtv ooh mtv all day right
okay so that's i don't think anybody's
ever picked ph once you're over 50.
i mean i was i was like happy that vh1
had those music videos in the morning it
was like needed something to get ready
to but like mtv took over and then next
was on all the other cool stuff when i
was a kid i got me too i was hooked um
here we go adam sandler or jim carrey
ooh adam sandler yeah i feel like i
watched um it was a big daddy so much i
just watched it
two days ago i watched it so much and 50
first dates oh 50 oh we've had a long
discussion
real quick
he he he is just dating a woman
that can't remember him
and she wakes up next to this man every
day every day is that morally okay that
they're having a baby she's waking up
pregnant one day
oh but they didn't have that
it wasn't because they just fast
forwarded two years and they have a
child on the boat what was her six-month
pregnant wake-up day like wake up six
months pregnant and have to get calmed
down by this strange stranger sorry we
go into detail here i feel like if he
asked her every day if she wanted a kid
and she said yes then morally it's okay
i know but every day she looks down like
what's my options [ __ ] you got
me on a boat
it was just that one day she had one day
to pick yeah sorry that's yeah we go to
50 first dates heavy it's a good
question
all right all right all right here we go
uh tupac biggie smalls what are you
picking as a kid ah i think tupac all
right all right okay is it because
you're from california and it was on the
rate like it's i think i just like
probably went on the lyric websites and
looked at his lyrics a little longer so
i was just like more invested
all right did you were you listening to
hip-hop growing up oh yeah i was like i
always tell adam like if you ask me
about the g unit era i can i can ask
answer your questions but if you ask i
don't when i go on apple music and i
click like the title
i have no idea who anyone is unless he
tells me okay that's smarty anything
past 2001 he goes what
his alzheimer's was yeah that's how i
feel too yeah yeah
everything and he's from new york so
he's all about it ready
step by step or family matters
as a kid too you have to pick
because girls always go step by step i
think i feel like i only vaguely
remember both of those shows i want to
say family matters
i i go family matters okay because urkel
was just funny
i mean everybody at school
did urkel you remember the 90s yeah
that's all everybody [ __ ] talked
about that was the me before the memes
it the clown or chucky oh i want to say
none because i [ __ ]
hate everything scary but chucky i have
more memories of being afraid of chucky
yeah it was too i couldn't yeah thomas
is violently afraid
i don't want that i don't even like
hearing just like the scary music like
a black screen like nothing nothing
scary it's too much for me
i'm [ __ ] good
there we go pulp fiction or forrest gump
pulp fiction yeah but i only recently
shoot so
it's such a good movie there there's a
scene in pulp fiction where someone's
wearing a uc santa cruz yeah the slugs
yes yes so i feel like very connected to
it all right yeah i like that you
noticed that i know exactly what scenes
well they still sell that shirt at the
bay tree bookstore so that's why it's
time to look at collectors
yeah no my homie went there too so i was
up there all the time
here we go
mario or donkey kong as a kid
i feel like i feel like i played more
donkey kong as a kid like
adam like i feel like my cousins had
that game and when i was at their house
i was playing because i was young i
didn't really like have video games but
yeah i think i have more memories adam's
the only person ever big dog oh
oh the only two people that that's
everything that's surprising mario
all right here we go mcdonald's or
burger king i know this answer
burger king sandwich
burger king chicken sandwich my fat ass
wanted that as a kid
that's what i thought as a kid that's
what i always got all right here we go
here we go michael jackson or michael
jordan
oh michael jackson michael jackson i
think as a kid
most most people would pick you go to
camp and they teach you the thriller
dance and you do okay that's true i feel
like i didn't very michael jackson
related things and the electric slide
yeah yeah he's kind of just kind of sure
if you're not like a basketball playing
kid i guess yeah that's true that's true
ready
sunny d or nesquik with a little rabbit
on it
none and also both of those grossed me
out if i thought about drinking them
right now oh right now but i'm much more
into chocolate milk so as a kid just mix
in that [ __ ] i would put extra chocolate
on my shirt it's so annoying get the
powder clumps in your mouth because you
couldn't actually for sure yeah she
would use a whisk someone should have
told us about risks my grandma had one i
never wanted to like go get the [ __ ] as
a kid everything is a troll yeah oh more
[ __ ] no [ __ ] that i'll drink the cups so
that's how i thought about it too
hey we got through that great good [ __ ]
great [ __ ] nice good answers man
fastest one for real okay um i know you
have to the bathroom i know we're gonna
get you out of here we've been here for
quite a while hour and a half so i've
been here for a minute thank you very
much for being here yeah of course it
was fun i was about to go hey marty
how'd you
that's the first setup he used to be
over there it would have a different
tape which is so odd this is so much
it's so much better man is it the first
episode you didn't smoke weed on
no
in a while
do you always smoke weed we usually
always smoke weed i completely forgot i
was like honestly like scared i was like
[ __ ] they're gonna smoke weed around me
i'm gonna get high no we always ask
that's when you stand and go oh yeah i'm
not gonna spark our guests if they don't
have to ask usually before because adam
isn't gonna [ __ ] he just lights up
around me and then i'm at the no jumper
offices where everyone smokes and i'm
like there's no [ __ ] windows
i'm high now i need to go home yeah i
see i don't want to do that to people
with brian callum we had him come here
he's like oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] i feel a little bit uh i feel a
little bit [ __ ] up right now you hit
the joint once
i don't want to do that to people so i
like not i'm not sure if it's in my head
or if i really get contact in my head
it's probably no no you get contact time
but the paranoia is in your head yeah
it's just it's just that and you know
and you're on camera you're like did i
say something stupid yeah i can't
remember like am i talking loud enough
can they hear you i
but thank you so much for being here
thank you for coming yes of course first
fan ever you i mean the first guest ever
you were here like one time like
[Applause]
i'd rather have to fill up my gas tank
again than be [ __ ] late to a meeting
yeah like i'd rather like can you give
me like i'd buy 20 minutes from you
right now please so once you have a kid
just know
almost you might be late sometimes i
know but that's my excuse they're like
they [ __ ] their diaper they [ __ ] you
put their shoes on they just stick them
right back
the house though they're gonna up like
oh [ __ ] they already started the car
he's gonna leave without me
yeah that's pretty much how i'll be um
all right i think i think that's
everything marty everything i wanted to
get through yeah thank you thank you so
much for being here i appreciate it
where can everybody find your new show
uh it's on my youtube channel uh
youtube.com lana the plug
just all one word lana the plug yeah
okay cool and then on insta i mean
what's your new instagram oh it's okay
you guys can just google me but at
freeland of the plug free okay so which
which number is this
it's all they're all out of order
because i'll make a new one and i'll get
one of them back and then the ip so i
had like one of the plug and now it's
free lana the plug and then when that
one got deleted i had lana the plug
again but now len of the plug again is
deleted now this
just google and you know what just
follow me on twitter because that's the
only place i never [ __ ] get deleted
all one word guys all right on twitter
thank you so much for being here and
good luck on your new show i hope
everything goes well the set looks
awesome thank you thank you that looks
really nice marty thank you so much for
being here thank you sir thank you so
much for being here guys this has been
the dope as usual podcast i'm dope yola
have a dope ass day
what so yesterday i did a edible
challenge oh my gosh like 3 000
milligrams last night woke up so
violently high this morning i'm like no
no she's gonna be here in three hours
like what did you do i chugged all this
water in this juice
and it helped it helps so much
i feel okay
[Music]